some people move on but not us. Not us.
Hey everybody its charlie happy
Superbowl Sunday we got a brand new
Avengers endgame trailer to break down
we're doing a new round of the Amazon
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from the trailer on the
video so the big message of this is just
their big rally cry like you actually
see them walking in the background in
the avengers facility it's not all the
avengers but i'll explain what's going
on in these frames because most of it
looks like genuine footage from the film
with like maybe a few minor omissions
like Hulk for instance because of the
way hook is going to look during the movie so you're getting Captain America's
voice over through the entire trailer
but they flash through a couple really
quick cuts before the big Marvel Studios
logo so all these frames aren't just the
dead people is just meant to represent
each of the different franchises each of
the different big character groups from
the Avengers but some of these
characters did get snapped by Thanos so
you start with the wasp and you also
notice the way that they color corrected
this so they took out everything but the
blacks and reds that's just meant to match the color
scheme of the Marvel Studios red and
black logo that you see as it gets
dusted and you move into the actual
trailer so you start with the wasp in
the post-credits scene from the first
ant-man movie then you go to the scene
of Nick Fury from the beginning of the
first Avengers film when they were
arriving at the base to go check out why
the tesseract was going so crazy then
you have spider-man's big introduction
during civil war with Captain America's
shield they also did the really cool thing in the trailer by ending on the
moment with caps cinching up his new
shield somebody got that man a new
shield they cut to the scene from the Doctor Strange movie where he earns the
respect of the cloak of levitation and
puts it on in that big sweeping slow-mo
montage there's the Falcon seen from the
beginning of Captain America Civil War
when you got to see him use his wings
and really badass way for the first time
then there's the scene from infinity war
with Scarlet Witch protecting vision
from the black orders attack they jump
to the scene from the first guardians
movie in the kiln when they had
assembled for the first time in the
elevator doors open in slow motion like
we're the guardians of the galaxy they
cut to the scene from black panther when
he was entering sharees lab for the
first time early in the film there's a
scene from Captain America Winter
Soldier where Winter Soldier caught
Captain America shield that was actually
in the original trailer for that movie
because it was such a badass moment
another big reference to Captain America
sheíll there are three within this
trailer so that's no coincidence then there's the scene from the end of
Avengers age of Ultron with vision
descending getting ready to face Ultron
for the last time and then they sweet to
that logo of a Marvel Studios getting
dusted away so remember it's all meant
to be the same color scheme the red and
black of the logo but then you jump to
the actual trailer footage in the way
that they bleed the color out of this
just makes it look that much more bleak
because this is all post snap we don't
know exactly how much time has gone by
but enough time as you see later in the
trailer for there to be some sort of
national campaign with a bunch of
posters like what do we do now that
everybody's gone you get a really
desolate shot of Manhattan from the
river then you get this really creepy
shot of the Statue of Liberty with all
these empty boats that look like they've
either washed up there or they've been
collected there like there were a bunch
of people that were using their boats in
and around Manhattan that got dusted so
they all maybe just drifted towards the
Statue of Liberty or somebody just tried
to clean up the area and collected them
there so that there wouldn't be a danger
to other people in the river then they
cut to a shot of Citi Field and you see
what looks like a military vets survivor
group with Captain America meeting with
a bunch of other old military vets
they're probably talking about people
that they lost during Wars people that
they lost to the snap because this is the same type of support group that you
would have for normal military vets
after they come back from a tour of duty
like if they have trouble acclimating or
if one of their friends died or one of
their squad mates so you see Captain
America going to a grief counseling
group with these other old military vets
and you see the poster like I said what
do we do now that they're gone so it
seems like the world has now been
dealing with the trauma of this in a
bunch of different ways then we cut to
probably one of the most interesting
shots in the trailer Tony Stark looking
like he's getting his Iron Man went on
remember the shot from the first Iron
Man trailer when he was stuck in the cave and he has started to make the Iron
Man mark 1 suit
it almost looks exactly like this shot
here so that's his rally moment very
clearly he's going to help MacGyver his own way out of this situation with a little
bit of help from nebula who's macgyvering something behind him so team
nebula and Tony for a little while during the movie confirmed but a lot of
people have been expecting Iron Man's
classic suits and suits that are
inspired by his classic comic-book suits
to appear during the film these visual
references to scenes from the original
phase 1 movies just implies that there's
going to be a lot of Easter eggs and
callbacks to that there's a shot of
everybody from the last trailer that we
saw at the New Avengers facility looking
up in the field at the New Avengers
facility like somebody's arriving in a
ship that could be Tony Stark and nebula
arriving then you get a shot of rocket
entering what looks like some sort of
small hut or wooden shed or something
like that this could be in Wakanda
because it definitely looks like Thor is
in Wakanda and one of the other shots in
the trailer but you actually go straight
to Black Widow in the New Avengers
facility just dealing with her rage by
shooting the targets this is just meant
to show her getting really pissed off
because the Captain America voiceover
happening during this is starting to
build to that moment where he's like not
us we don't get over it like they're
getting ready to rally as the voiceover
builds to a crescendo you get ant-man
putting his helm down war machine
putting his helm down like they're
moving into battle getting ready to
start doing something then you get a
shot of Thor somewhere else in the world
it's kind of hard to tell where he is he
has both eyes and a lot of people wonder
about the shot from him in the last
trailer where it seems like he only has
one eye either it's a continuity issue
or it's just a different part of the
film entirely I wouldn't worry too much
about that those are the parts that they
can be very misleading about because
Marvel will CG in and out certain things
so that you don't know exactly quite
what's going on but there's another shot
of Thor here with Stormbreaker with his
full armor and his cape on and it looks
like he's in Wakanda just based on the
architecture and you look at the
greenery in the background that just
looks like the mountains of Wakanda then
you jump to a shot of Hawkeye somewhere
else and what looks like a giant crash
behind him like something has gone down
and he's getting ready for battle like
he's moving and you see this red light
on his face so this could be somebody
hostile remember Hawkeye does not know
anything about what's going on with the
guardians so this could be another scene
like infinity war when the guardians
came up on the Avengers in Thanos his
ship without realizing what was going on
you are chill the f out I'm going to ask
you this one time where is Gamora yeah
I'll do you one better
who's Gamora I'll do you one better why is Gamora tell me where the girl is
or I swear to you I'm going to french fry
this little freak let's do it you shoot
my guy and I'll blast him let's go right
you can't oh yeah you don't want to tell
me where she is that's fine I'll kill
all three of you when I'll beat it then
you get the new shot of Captain America
hands trembling as he cinches up his new
shield like damn I mean business time to
go kick some ass so we don't really know
exactly how he gets this but remember
the spider-man homecoming scene with all
the Avengers prototypes that happy was
loading onto the back of the plane one
of them was the prototype for Cap's new
shield it sounds like that's what this
shield is prototype for Cap's new shield
and the making the magic then you get
the rally moment in the voiceover is
like not us and they have the Avengers
theme start playing and everybody goes
crazy and it's basically them walking
into battle like all right we're going to
start whatever planet is they come up
with when ant-man arrives so the thing
is though is that not all of the
Avengers are in this shot this is pretty
much everybody except for the Hulk Iron
Man and nebula so it's probably earlier
in the film before Iron Man and nebula
make it back going from the front of the
line to the back of the line it's
Captain America then Thor walking behind him then Black Widow then rocket then
ant-man in his suit and then war machine
behind him the biggest reason why Hulk
might not be in this shot is because
he's supposed to be Professor Hulk and
looked different so the Russos may have
just digitally removed him from this
shot to prevent people from seeing what
he looks like prematurely or maybe they
haven't finished the special effects for
it yet but it just seems like one of
those infinity war trailer moments where
you see Thanos' gauntlet and it has a
couple of gems removed so that you don't
know exactly what's going on in this
scene but there were a couple big Easter
eggs during this most notably the return
of Captain America shield or his brand
new prototype shield that Iowan was
making for him and the Iron Man nebula
seen on their ship while they're stuck
there trying to MacGyver their way off
that's meant to be a mirror for Tony
I've ring up the Iron Man suit mark 1 so
that he could escape the cave I can
imagine him trying to tell nebula that
story did I ever tell you about the time
that I got blown up and thrown in a cave
it's kind of like us being stuck on this
ship so let's find a way out of here
there'll be a whole bunch more Super
Bowl trailers dropping this weekend
maybe some more Avengers footage soon so
leave all your requests in the comments
below and let me know if you spotted any
big easter eggs that I didn't mention in
the video I'll name a giveaway winner
when I post new Marvel click here for
that brand new Captain Marvel Super Bowl Trailer
and click here for that other
Avengers endgame trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight!